hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book eight of his institute's John
Cassian is considering the spirit of
anger and anger is among the eighth
Capital vices that will then later
become seven deadly sins and he wants to
head off a likely we could call it sort
of excuse or practice that a number of
people will engage in including the
monks that he's writing to and they will
use scripture as a justification for
this because there is this injunction
from Paul let not the sun go down on
your anger and so it sounds at least to
certain people like well okay so I have
to stop being angry when it's bedtime or
night time but during the day
I'm not letting the sun go down on my
anger if I retain my anger over the
course of the day so that's okay right
you know I just have to be able to turn
it off when the light goes out or the
sun goes down or something like that and
Cassian is saying no that's not really
establishing a as we can call it lawful
limit or boundary the Latin term there
is leaket which means you know like
observing certain Norms he's saying no
that's a that's a bad idea why because
what you're doing is you are indulging
your anger and rage for a certain time
and that's going to be problematic for
you right it'll give full play as he
says to passion and dangerous excitement
and it's interesting here I I've
remarked at different places that
Cassian tends to use two different terms
uh furor rage is how we translate it and
then era anger right and he talks about
the satisfaction of our wrath satitam
furores right so if we indulge that
we're gonna we're gonna have some
problems and then the uh Vengeance of
anger otriches right these are the two
things that go hand in hand with each
other so we don't want to just use that
notion of well
you know maybe eight hours is okay but
nine hours isn't and why well because
it's going to lead us into all sorts of
problems and then he goes on uh and he
says even worse and very interestingly
here he says I cannot say it without
shame on my own part so chaosian is
himself fessing up that he has he's done
this
um worse is when one's implacability and
that's just a translation of the Latin
term implacabilitas right an inability
or unwillingness to be placated to be
satisfied to let one's anger and one's
offense go so one's implacability as he
says extends anger over a set of days
not allowing or allowing the sun to go
down on your anger and then rise and
continuing it on so he says
um nourishing rancorous feelings against
those against whom they've been excited
and the rancorous feelings is actually
just Rancor Rancor this kind of
bitterness
right so nourishing that within one's
own self
um and then he says something very
interesting here he says that they
deny negroens right they they say I I'm
not angry don't worry about me they deny
in words in verbis that they're angry
but they show or actually this is a very
strong term
they prove of themselves
systematically you could say that they
are actually angry and how do they do
this so he says in two different
modalities in fact
right in the matters themselves and in
their deeds in their actions Opera in
the deed literally so these are people
that are engaging in what we would
nowadays probably call passive
aggressivity right they're they're still
angry so they do things oops I didn't
mean to knock over your plant that you
got in your cubicle I was just you know
passing by and I was careless I'm not
angry at you I didn't do it because I
was angry I deny that but really that's
what I was doing you know these are the
people who have a sour bitter attitude
towards others even though they deny it
and and so what Cassian says that
they're doing
which is quite dangerous
is that they you know they don't speak
to these people pleasantly or address
them with ordinary Civility and they
think that they're not doing wrong in
this why because they're not seeking to
avenge themselves for their upset
but he says since they don't dare or are
not able to show their anger openly they
drive it in to their own detriment they
drive the poison of anger as he is going
to call it into their very own heart and
they secretly cherish it and feed on it
in themselves without shaking off by an
effort of mind their sulky disposition
we'll come back to that in just a moment
and then he says but digesting it as the
days go by somewhat mitigating it over a
while right so there are people who you
know they they're not allowed to or they
feel that they can't express their anger
openly so they nourish it within their
hearts and that's that's not good for
them and that leads to what's being
translated here is sulkiness
the more literal translation of this
would be sadness or dejection
tristityi right and this is actually
among the eight Capital vices and anger
does in fact lead to this uh kind of
sadness or sorrow is another way of
translating it that is not good for a
person when it can't be expressed I mean
this is sort of a very early insight
about some people's depression being
anger directed inward or retained within
themselves a despair could be also
connected with that as well so you know
not letting the sun go down in your
anger you really shouldn't hold on to it
that long you definitely don't want to
hold on to it for days and days and
leave it in your heart and show it in
these passive aggressive ways and then
he also says it looks as if this was not
the end of Vengeance to everybody some
can only completely satisfy their wrath
or sulkiness if they carry out the
impulse of anger as far as they are able
some sort of Revenge you know it doesn't
necessarily have to be in kind oh you
destroyed my car I'm going to destroy
your car it could be you know I'm gonna
report this person anonymously oh I'm
gonna get them I'm going to talk about
them behind their back it could be
whatever means you want but it's being
driven by as he says both wrath and
sulkiness
and so he tells us that this is even
more problematic we're not restraining
the feelings the emotions the motives
within us the the drive uh from a desire
to calm them which would be a good
motive right uh instead what we're
trying to do is deal with our own
inability or as it is translated here
lack of opportunity in opium and you
know Opus is deed right so inopia means
like being in a condition being unable
to carry out what it is that you want to
do so an inability to carry out a sort
of Revenge right so what do these people
do he brings up this thing again he they
can do nothing more sometimes than speak
without ordinary civility they're harsh
they're thoughtless not really
thoughtless but just pretending to be
they're me they're hard they're they're
quick with the person they don't want to
hear what they have to say and all of
this would be along those lines of
passive aggressivity and he says this
looks as if anger was to be moderated
only in action not to be altogether
rooted out from its hiding places in our
heart and so that's a problem right why
because wrath that is nursed in the
heart is causing darkening or darkness
in our minds that one way of
interpreting the sun going down is that
anger itself makes the sun of our
intellects or Minds go down in its its
feeling right so this is uh affecting
the person as well and he tells us that
were unable not only to admit the light
of wholesome counsel and knowledge but
also be a temple of the Holy Spirit we
can't uh have any Divine aid but it also
prevents us from having wholesome
counsel and knowledge right so that
that's a central problem again a good
reason why not to retain anger within
our hearts uh the last thing that he
really says along these lines has to do
with another interesting scriptural
verse this is from the gospel of Matthew
from the famous Sermon on the Mount
where uh Jesus actually tells people if
your brother has something against you
then leave your gift the sacrifice that
you're bringing at the altar go be
reconciled to your brother then come
back and make your gift so you're
supposed to suspend whatever religious
activities that you're involved in until
you've straightened out this other thing
that is presumably a little bit more
important not having anger rank or fear
or in your heart against your fellow
human being and so he says
um
how then may we retain displeasure
against our brother I will not say for
several days but even this the going
down of the sun if we're not allowed to
offer prayers to God when he has
anything against us if we're supposed to
pray without ceasing which a lot of
Christians think you're supposed to do
and certainly Cassian thinks you're
supposed to do and in every place
lifting up hands without wrath and
disputing then we're in a dilemma like
he says well either we never pray at all
which is a bad idea right because we
retain this poison in our hearts and
become guilty or if else if deceiving
ourselves we venture to pour forth our
prayers we know we're offering to God no
prayer but obstinate temper with
rebellious spirit so long as we hold on
to our anger so long as we retain it
even if we think we're Justified we are
interfering with our very relationship
with the Divine and the Divine has
revealed this to human beings so casting
is saying another good reason not to
retain anger within yourself it's always
going to be
problematic except for of course when we
turn our anger against our own vices
which he discusses elsewhere so these
are some pretty strong reasons for not
holding on to not you know keeping in
mind the anger that we inevitably are
going to feel against other people the
idea here is that we should as soon as
we can get rid of or let go of that
anger so it doesn't interfere with our
understanding doesn't get in the way of
our relationships and doesn't cause us
further damage harm and trouble